tous
[Musique]
donc le service militaire adapté a été
créée en 1961 par le général des mots à
la demande du premier ministre de
l'époque
monsieur debré pour répondre à problèmes
socio-économiques dans les antilles pour
commencer puisque il y avait une grosse
crise sociale et que ça permettait de
répondre en partie à la structuration
des territoires et départements
d'outre-mer passer des ateliers aux usa
prennent
[Musique]
le sm a fait ses 60 ans et c'est une
vraie institution qui s'est installée en
outre-mer dans les années 60 et le sénat
travaille sur les questions de
citoyenneté et le cema à part entière
fixe à 6000 jeunes qui passent chaque
année entre les mains des encadrants un
cadre de citoyenneté apprendre à lire à
écrire à conduire à compter ça peut
paraître basique mais c'est souvent la
base de la citoyenneté et pour un
certain nombre de jeunes qui sont
éloignés le sm a c'est une vraie
opportunité et le sénat s'intéresse à
toutes ces questions sociétales
sociologique il est donc important et le
président du sénat est très engagé sur
les autres maire souhaitait évidemment
valoriser cette action au profit
d'autres honneurs
dans l'expo il ya deux séries de photos
il ya une série donc fait à périgueux
qui a été fait au printemps dernier et
une autre série qui a été fait pendant
les répétitions pour le 14 juillet j'ai
travaillé beaucoup sous l'angle du
portrait j'ai fait aussi bas avec bien
sûr des photos des lieux dans lesquels
il y vit
voilà et puis essayer de à travers ces
images décrire voilà une jeunesse
d'outre-mer qu'on connaît mal ici en
métropole essayez bas grâce à ces photos
voilà de rapprocher un peu un peu les
gens et de de combler le fossé de
l'ignorance qui peut y avoir parfois
entre la métropole et les territoires
nos autres verte c'est quelque chose
d'important mais on a des élus très
engagé
et la dénégation que président c'est pas
leur canot se préoccupe aussi de cette
dimension n'est pas kurde et dimension
institutionnelle et aussi sur des vi
nations le sociologique et social merci
mon général
[Musique]